hello and welcome to another edition of
down the middle with d martino booth
i am danielle d martino booth and it is
my great pleasure and honor to have with
us today
mike green i first learned of mike's
work i don't know why only about a year
ago
uh where have you been mike is my first
question
uh and it's it's so
incredibly important that you listen to
everything that michael has to say about
the foundations
of passive investing indexing
what got us to that point there is a
history there
but first we're gonna start off with a
bit of
background on mike so uh
it was our collective senior year in
high school
walk like an egyptian was the number one
song i can
i've still got every single lyric down
walk like an egyptian every single one
october let's see no august the 11th
so we're just getting ready to go back
to school a gentleman by the name of
alan greenspan has his first day at work
at the federal reserve so we go to
school after
labor day and uh come
come sunday august excuse me come sunday
october the 18th
you're talking your parents into playing
hooky the next day can you uh can you
explain
uh well in really simple terms it wasn't
actually even playing hooky the next day
it was as we woke up in the morning
uh the news was that the market was
crashing so i was in california so i had
the advantage of a three-hour delay
so by the time i'm awake at 6 30 in the
morning
there's an extraordinary event in play
in new york city
and i of course convince my parents that
i'm running a fever
and not feeling well and i'm gonna have
to stay home from school
both of them worked um and they were you
know pretty much okay well
you know you're 17 years old you know
what you're doing um
as long as you're not telling us it's
test etc it was a monday so
you know fairly reasonable hadn't been
out drinking the night before or
anything like that
and um long story short i stayed home
and watched the crash of 87 on
on the tv and this is like it was day
off but it's like mike green's day yeah
exactly
this is yes ferris bueller travels
throughout chicago doing all sorts of
interesting things mike green sits in
front of the tv with a bowl of cereal
and
and watching the world fall apart it was
just i mean it really was one of those
things that you had to watch if you had
any interest whatsoever in financial
markets
um and at that point i had already
applied for early acceptance to the
university of pennsylvania and so i
kind of knew i was going to head off to
wall street or
you know at least to wharton at least
initially
and i just i couldn't miss the event and
it was worth every
you know every moment of that uh that
that fake sore throat and fever
i mean you could not have chosen had you
engineered it homemade you could not
have chosen a better time
to go put four years in in school as
1987 turned out to be a moment
not an event yeah
how was it though going from a west
coast i mean you grew up valley guy
how was that transitioning over to
pennsylvania yeah well for me actually
it was weird because it felt
very much the minute i walked onto the
penn campus and and wharton
uh school it literally felt like i was
going home um
you know i had always had kind of an
intensity on the west coast
that uh i would say is it's a more rel
you know the west coast is much more
relaxed
in these components and and so i always
had a relatively high level of intensity
on either academic subjects or things
that i was interested in
hitting the east coast for the first
time you come into contact with new
yorkers and people from new jersey
and you know all of a sudden there's
kind of that intensity and speed that's
missing when you're growing up on the
west coast
and surrounded by people who are into
surfing and all sorts of stuff
i certainly had my fair share of that
but uh for me it was a very natural
transition and i really didn't have
any compelling reason to go back to
california
other than a period in the 1990s i moved
back to california it started and ran a
software company that i then sold in 99
but other than that brief window i never
really spent any time in california
moved back in 2017 and now i can
actually sit back and enjoy a little bit
more of the relaxed pace i'm sitting
here without shoes on and uh
enjoying myself and my my uh shelter at
home
uh office with a really cool background
by the way
i mean that's it's it's just an old map
of uh
san francisco bay so it's uh if if i
were to put my
my arm up you can basically find me
right right up there
so cool well um so
let's go back further than that let's go
back
to no no we're not going to go back into
it into the days that you you know you
might have been drinking the night
before no we're not going there
um let's go back to
the beginning of markets what
was a market and when did the market
that we refer to it today because if
you're
if you're talking to anybody and what
would the market do today and they're
talking about
the stock market but that certainly was
not always the case
well it certainly wasn't the case so
when you talk about markets i mean
markets themselves
think about you know the the most
traditional form of it is just a you
know you go to a souk right or you go to
a market where people are selling wares
you're effectively being bringing
together uh
those who have acquired goods and those
who are seeking goods
right um that's all a stock market is
it's just a market that happens to be
for pieces of paper that represent
various
corporate entities right and so most
people tend to forget
that history they don't they think of it
as differently than going to the store
because it is actually different right
very few of us grew up in an environment
where we had exposure to a souk
or a you know a
flea market sort of environment where
there's negotiating and haggling that's
going on
but that's all the stock market is is
it's effectively the meeting of people
who want to haggle over the price of
those pieces of the paper what we refer
to
as q and so the the data that we see on
markets is actually just a history of
transactions that have occurred in those
markets
right and that's kind of one of the
important things to remember as we think
about what markets are doing
there's buyers and they're sellers we
only see the inter the intersection of
those two where a transaction actually
occurs we don't have any data in terms
of what was the market depth
we don't know how deep was the market
prior to the crash of 1987 we don't know
how deep was the market prior to the
crash in 1929
we don't know what the tipping point was
in terms of those underlying components
and for me that's the most interesting
part about markets is trying to actually
understand
what happens when you step just outside
of where that transaction occurred
if it had gone another point if it had
gone two more points
was there depth that then would have
created a discontinuity
and that was really for me the most
interesting thing
that i've learned since coming out of
the theoretical background
in high school in college is all of the
models that we
we use and we assume when we think about
markets when we talk about efficient
market hypothesis or we talk about
modern portfolio theory
or we talk about the crash of 1987 and
the assumptions that sat behind it
the assumptions are one of a continuous
market where you can always transact
and what 1987 really was was a
discontinuous market
it was a market where the next
transaction was so large
that nobody was willing to stand in
front of it
so when did the modern stock market as
we think
of it is this is was was this a moment
under a tree in new york
uh in front of the new york stock
exchange as we know it today did it
precede that
well there are there are histories of
stock markets that go back to the early
1600s right so we have the examples of
the dutch stock market with the dutch
east india company etc so those
have been around for four or 500 years
but when we talk about a modern stock
market right there's never a
there's a contemporary stock market
there's never a modern stock market
right it's constantly undergoing
evolution
and so if you look back to the
buttonwood tree and i think it was 1789
in terms of the founding of the new york
stock exchange
or what they label as the founding of
the new york stock exchange you know you
were trading claims on companies
primarily fixed income there was some
element of equity trading that was going
on
equity did not resemble what we talked
about today they were in many situations
full liability corporations so your
analysis would have to include
could you be sued or could you be held
liable for the debts that were incurred
by this entity
over and above the capital that had been
invested and
those things have changed over the past
200 years right the rules of what we're
transacting the definition of what we're
transacting the
obligations and rights associated with
that
have all changed in its most modern you
know form to use the language that you
you describe i would suggest that
most of what we think of as the stock
market today
kind of began in the early 1980s with
the introduction
of products like futures with the
introduction of
liquid option markets and
a tremendous growth of both fixed income
and
equity markets on exchanges
that might not have existed prior to
that right pink sheets for example were
actually a real thing and there were
many companies that were not actively
traded on exchanges
those rules began to change quite
dramatically with the introduction of
the dealer brokerage market the nasdaq
right the
national association of securities
dealers which created markets for those
etcetera
so i like i kind of would put it back to
that 1981 1982 time period which of
course feels like the beginning of the
the first you know great bull market
which i might suggest has actually
continued
um but that would kind of be where i
would start if you're starting to think
about it and again i was just very
fortunate to come into
a theoretical understanding of that at a
relatively young age
you know kind of 12 years 10 years into
the
the modern market to again use the
lexicon
um so along those same lines
uh when was when was the s
p 500 when did that come about
uh and in fact probably the next person
i i interview after you
gonna be a dear friend of mine howard
silverblatt who's he's only been with s
p for
i think 43 or 44 years now um he's a
walking talking spreadsheet it's just
frightful uh and when when there's a
shift in this index
it's it's a monumental moment inside s p
but how long has the spider
you know dollar sign sbx how long has
that
existed so the s p itself was created in
1957.
um at the time it had only 200 stocks in
the index and then it was
widened to 500 stocks in a tradable
format there used to be a product
referred to as in the
initial introduction of futures there
was something called the oex which was
the s p 100
that was far more liquid in terms of
trading activity
than the s p 500 was in large part
because the calculation intensity
the ability to get a computer to very
quickly run a replication or an
arbitrage construction on 500 stocks
was far more difficult than to do it on
100 stocks gives you some idea of the
advances that have occurred in our lives
frames used to take up entire rooms
exactly i i
very distinctly remember um sitting
in a uh investment training course at
spear leads in kellogg where i
worked when i was at penn
and you know a representative from
merrill lynch came in and explained that
the street now
had a full pentabyte
of information in terms of data that had
been collected in terms of the total
amount of information that was available
on wall street right and you you
stop and you think about how quaint that
is today relative to
you know we're all sitting around on our
desktops at the time i think the
ibm at had just come out and had a
30 megabyte hard drive right and so you
know that's a small email attachment
today
um so the world has changed quite
dramatically over that time period but
the the spx began in 1957 it was
introduced in futures forum in 1982.
um you know we can talk through some of
these components but you know one of my
favorite
uh references is actually going back to
that point warren buffett
in a 1982 commentary to the sec that
actually was then
published in business week magazine
another somewhat archaic craft friends
um in 19 after the crash in 1987
it was brought to light that warren
buffett's commentary on futures was he
could
see a quote as i see logical
risk-reducing strategy
that involves shorting the futures
contract i see no corresponding
investment or hedging strategy
whatsoever on the long side
and so when you think about futures and
and kind of the swashbuckling you know
paul tudor jones of the 1980s
what was really going on with futures
throughout that entire time period is
that they were the province of commodity
traders they were the province of people
who were either looking to
hedge out their risk jim chanos famously
started kinecos advisors using futures
to offset the
equity market exposure exposing his
alpha for example
but nobody really had a use for futures
for another
almost 14 years 13 years it wasn't
really until the mid-1990s that we began
to use them
in something that resembles their
current form where significant
use was was created on the long side
well that kind of brings us uh back in
time i remember
when i was on wall street and i first
started to sense
what the federal reserve was and the
role it was playing but in your
evolution
as an investor in your evolution as
a student of the markets and somebody's
studying the structure
when did the when did the federal
reserve first come onto your radar
screen because it was a lot later
in life than october the 20th 1987 when
alan greenspan put out an advisory that
the federal reserve stood ready to back
the banking and financial systems and
within
days and weeks was leaking information
to wall street bond trading desks ahead
of fed moves to inject liquidity in the
system
is it 1987 that the fed put was born but
i didn't know squad about the fed until
me personally that the run-up to the 90s
uh that the dot-com
days yeah so so people tend to forget
that when alan greenspan came on as you
pointed out
he started in august and by october we
had a crisis on our hands right so
paul volcker was viewed as you know the
greatest fed chair in history he had
saved america from inflation
now i obviously you know you may have
heard me dispute that
and i have some real questions about
those dynamics
but alan greenspan did step in in 1987
and did something really important it
wasn't so much that he
offered to bail out the banking system
as what he really did was he facilitated
the provision of
lines of credit and made good the lines
of credit for the market makers right
the specialist firms
so i mentioned spear leads in kellogg
which was the largest specialist firm on
the new york stock exchange at the time
i actually traded commodities for them
but the the challenge that you had as a
market maker
is that you used large amounts of
leverage against a relatively small
capital base to facilitate orderly
transactions
in a then manual order book where orders
would come in
and you would actually try to match a
buyer and seller and if there was an
inability to match that buyer and seller
you would put your capital up against it
and so in the crash of 87 the specialist
firms had extended
their capital and used borrowed money to
buy stocks
to try to facilitate a liquid market as
the market fell out from under them
the losses that they faced on those
books made their bankers their banking
relationships nervous
they then pulled the credit lines for
the specialist firms which destroyed the
liquidity effectively there was no bid
at that point and alan greenspan is in
the air
flying from dallas so you've got the
head of the new york stock exchange
i'm good friends with arthur cashion so
i wasn't in the pits at the time but
arthur cashion's walked me through that
day but continue
yeah i know so so art cashion actually
is the gentleman responsible for
getting a hold of alan greenspan and
saying look this thing is going to go
straight to zero unless you guarantee
the specialist firms and get these lines
of credit back open
that was where greenspan stepped in and
said okay listen we'll make you
we'll make the banking system whole on
any losses associated with specialist
firms not being able to make good on
these bets
right and that's really what they were
at that point is that they were bets
that was kind of the first introduction
of the fed put
it played a significant role in
halting the panic associated with 87
but interestingly enough i would
actually say that that that wasn't
really where the activist
it may have been where it was born but
that was kind of
untouched for a period of time like the
fed didn't really play
that active of a role in markets at
least on my analysis
until we came to kind of the ltcm type
dynamics
and at that point at least the
the the tequila crisis of mexico yep
orange county went poof in the same year
so
but yes long-term capital management
well with long-term capital management
something changed on a structural basis
right so the fed
suddenly began focusing its interest
rate activity its interest rate
movements
on not fighting inflation which is what
it had done
since basically the 1970s instead it
shifted to trying to manage the
expectations channel by preventing
collapse of asset prices
right so one of the challenges of the
1970s and the breakdown
and so now you have to go all the way
back you know to that time period if you
think about the 1970s
we kind of had this very simple
mechanistic view which is you know this
sort of keynesian
or post-keynesian view that what we
could manage demand by the government
increasing taxes increasing spending we
could keep unemployment low we could
keep the economy going etc
and in the 1970s many of those
relationships broke down
or at least indicated failure right so
the phillips curve for example which is
supposed to govern the relationship
between unemployment and inflation we
simultaneously had high unemployment and
high inflation which is not supposed to
happen
right the demand component and so the
fed
very much had to shift to fighting
inflation or at least what they thought
they were doing was fighting inflation
and that changed in 1998 and it became
very clear in terms of the relationship
of interest rates
and asset prices that what had been a
phenomenon of taking the punch bowl away
to use the the warren miller reference
the arthur miller i'm sorry um reference
warren miller is a ski
uh documentary maker um
the uh you know you took away
the the old reference was you would take
away the punch bowl by raising interest
rates and reducing speculation
post 1998 it became when a negative
financial event occurred i.e financial
conditions tightened
the fed would respond by cutting
interest rates to try to facilitate
borrowing to try to facilitate lending
activity etc
and that was a very substantive
structural change that occurred in 1998
it's very clear in the data and
in my view that's kind of the origin of
much of what we refer
to or bemoan as the activist fed
okay well i'll have to send you a very
boring paper i did about 1998 and
long-term capital management when i was
inside the fed
if you can get through compliance at the
federal reserve it's not going to be too
it won't keep you up so okay um
so 1998
uh at that time
where was vanguard where was passive
investing
where was there even an etf back then i
don't think so
um but but take us back to
1998 1995 that era
so if you go back to that point and and
you know if you're thinking about the
growth of passive investing or where
vanguard was right so
circa 1994 1995 vanguard and
all other index providers are less than
two percent market share
right so very small relative
to the overall investment universe
vanguard was obviously the leader even
at that point
but two important things happened in
that time period the first was in 1994
the levitt administration of the sec
uh did a giant study on derivatives
because the challenge that you had had
prior to that point
was that mutual funds were restricted
from using leverage
in most situations by the investment
company act of 1940
they were also prohibited from buying
securities they could have a first claim
on
assets effectively leveraged which
included derivatives and
in derivatives are also included futures
so the levitt administration did a giant
study in 1994
evaluating the risk of allowing mutual
funds to use derivatives
as in particular futures is really what
they were focused on less on puts and
calls
as we think of derivatives and the
reason that this
appears to have had a lot of impetus is
tied to the challenges that vanguard and
others
even at that small size were having in
maintaining their index
providers focus right so they began to
experience what's called tracking error
where you know you would issue an s p
fund you're supposed to very closely
track the index
but if you're not using futures to track
that index
you're forced to go out and try and buy
every individual security
some of those securities are much less
liquid than others
and by participating in that manner
you're influencing the price of those
securities
in your portfolio relative to the index
that then means that you have tracking
error and that's the kiss of death for
an index
provider strategy so that whole sec
investigation of derivatives in 1994
appears to have been done to facilitate
index providers beginning to use futures
and address this issue of tracking error
and when that happened it led to an
explosion of the utility of futures
right so as a equity market participant
in the late 1990s
while most people were very focused on
the dot-com dynamics
the single most interesting thing that
was actually happening was the explosion
of volume that was going through futures
and beginning to go into index funds
which grew rapidly from kind of two
percent
to about 10 over the next couple of
years
so um so that would be
if you will that watershed moment
was that was that the big bang for
passive investing
or was there more market history to come
it was was passive investing was there a
moment
later in time that it became the end-all
be-all because
it i and and actually at the time i mean
one of my biggest clients at the time
was trading massive spider
futures just massive hedging his
portfolio i mean the world was blowing
up i mean because i was on wall street
during the late 1990s
and you've got this other guy slinging
it around with with
spys every day in and out but was there
a
different catalyst was there a big bang
moment for passive investing so
that was one of the key catalysts right
so so that period 95 96 the beginning of
what greenspan referred to as a rational
exuberance
in my analysis this is largely tied to
the growth of passive investing in the
use of those futures and
and just very quickly the reason why
that happened was because the indices
were improperly constructed at the time
they were built on what's called a
market cap weighted basis
which means that you're trying to buy
shares in proportion to the total shares
outstanding
the unique feature of the 1990s was that
you had a number of large market cap
low float companies that had what we
used to refer to as high levels of
insider ownership and so these would be
companies
like walmart and microsoft and cisco and
dell
right when the index providers were
trying to buy these in proportion to
their market cap
relative rather than the float adjusted
weightings that were available the
actual
shares that you could have purchased it
meant
in companies like microsoft or dell that
you were trying to buy twice as many
shares as were actually available
if you try to buy twice as much of
something you're going to cause it to
outperform
that led to the dot-com cycle now
i sat outside this as a as a you know
value manager and and basically watched
some components of this
similar to what we're seeing today that
construction of indices led to dramatic
underperformance of value investing
because you were not
you know basically benefiting from this
so they tended to be older companies
that had all of their shares outstanding
etc right and they also did not fall
into the technology space
so there became some very serious
disconnects that occurred
um that was kind of the
first part of the growth of index
investing was the the facilitation of
that the second thing that happened was
in 2004
2005 they changed the structure of the
indices
and then a very important but you know
somewhat
um innocuous change was made in the 401k
space which was the introduction of what
were called qualified default investment
alternatives
and this is part of the pension
protection uh i think it's called the
pension protection
act of 2005. the idea was very simple
that up to that point if you went to
work for a company and you received a
401k
and you saved money into a 401k there
were two things that people were worried
about
one was relatively low levels of
participation in 401ks
that was a function of you as an
employee had to make a decision when you
joined a company that you were going to
participate in the 401k
so it was an active choice
um in 2005 they changed that they turned
it into a passive or the default choice
so that when you work
went to work for a company you were
automatically enrolled in a 401k
unless you refused to to do so
so that single change was huge in terms
of participation
the second thing that happened was when
you used to go to work for a company and
get a 401k you had to actively
choose what products you would invest in
if you didn't make a choice it would
just go into a money market fund and so
your money effectively would not be
invested
in 2005 that changed with the
introduction as i said of qdia's
qualified default investment
alternatives
which meant that your corporate hr
manager was selecting a fund that became
the default
and almost inevitably that became some
form of balanced
or passive vehicle and that was then
further changed in 2012
with additional regulatory changes under
the bureau of labor
the department of labor that switched it
almost exclusively to target date funds
and so target date funds have been by
far the fastest growing space
in the industry they've gone from
non-existent
in 2003 they literally did not exist
prior to 2003.
by 2012 they became the default and
today
nearly 80 percent of all dollars going
into 401ks are flowing into target date
funds
80 80
um the really crazy statistic is in
excess of 60 of 401ks now only have a
single vehicle in them which is the
target date fund
okay since i left the federal reserve
i've been doing my own investing so i'm
i'm really happy i don't know about
these
innovations shall we say no um
before moving on because i i want to get
to a congressional testimony uh that
janet yellen
gave a few years ago which i just
shocked me because she was
aware of etfs so that that was the first
part that shocked me
but when we hear the word
passive uh you know you you think of
something as as being the opposite of
assertive active aggressive
but explain in
just just consider me to be a monkey so
explain
how passive investing is not
passive so
just to very quickly define what people
refer to when they
typically talk passive versus active a
passive product is one
whose investment scheme the approach
that it takes to investing
has been built into an index or
into a methodology that does not change
over time and
almost when i refer to passive i'm
referring to things that are
float weighted or market cap weighted
not attempting to make
a distinct bet in terms of what are the
best companies what are the worst
companies
etc right no fundamentals
no you don't care about fundamentals you
are accepting the information that
you're receiving from the market
in terms of the last price is the right
price
right the rationale for
passive investing is tied back to the
efficient market hypothesis which is the
idea that as any individual
you can't outguess everybody else you
can't figure out information
better than everyone else and so in
aggregate
all of the active managers those who are
making active decisions in their
portfolios
will give you the same results as the
passive
exposure because you're buying the
market price and therefore
you're better off going with a passive
investment that can charge lower fees
because it's not actually trying to do
any quote-unquote work it's simply
riding off of everybody else's work
all right the challenge with that
is that if you look at the theoretical
underpinnings of that
model that theoretical model that
passive investing can piggyback on
it's built on the work of a gentleman
called bill sharp who won the nobel
prize in finance
for his work on things like modern
portfolio theory the cap-m model
sharp ratios etc um and
his paper in 1991 called the arithmetic
of active management
made a very simple declaration of what
passive investing was which is that a
passive investor
is one who never transacts they simply
maintain
exposure to the market right that was
the rationale behind it
the problem is is that that doesn't fit
the actual implementation of passive
because when you think about somebody
who's trying to have exposure to the
market
the only way that you can get that
exposure is by buying or
selling and the minute you do that it
makes you an
active investor you yourself become a
participant
who are now influencing market prices
that history of transactions that i
described is what a market represents or
market prices represent
you've now participated in it you've
joined
that stampede in one form or another and
the perverse aspect of passive investing
is that they are actually the most
motivated players
because they have the world's simplest
algorithms did you give me cash
if so then buy did you ask for cash
if so then sell there's no consideration
in that for what price should i buy at
what valuation should i buy at
should i maybe hold cash for a better
opportunity no
you can't do any of those things your
money is literally
just being forced into the market
regardless of the underlying conditions
so i mean you know to me what you're
describing sounds like
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars and we can pop a slide up at
some point where we can see the growth
of indexing which has been pretty
extraordinary
but but what you're describing is
trillions of dollars
of investors putting in a bunch of
orders at the market
which we were told was kind of risky
behavior because that
you were going to get somebody else's uh
price not the price you necessarily
needed to make sure that you got for
your client
but it just sounds like buy at the
market sell at the market
and i mean this can go on until you hit
infinity
so it's not quite that extreme but but
yes
and really you know to simplify yes that
is
you know i in no i do not think that
vanguard or blackrock is behaving in a
uh irresponsible manner trying to plow
those
dollars to work into the market they are
absolutely seeking best
execution within the market i have
complete faith that they're doing that
but what is being fit what people are
failing to consider and what our
research really focuses on
is the cumulative impact of continual
buying with no consideration for
fundamentals
and more importantly actually and this
is where our research is somewhat unique
is that we've focused on the dynamics of
what happens when you transition
between different investor types when
you move away
from the discretionary investor who's
thoughtful about
what does valuation mean if you fire
them
and give money to passive investments
that simply assume whatever price is the
right price
you're going to change the market itself
you're actually going to change the way
the market behaves
you're going to change the the values at
which
markets transact you're going to change
the value of cash
right so under an active manager or a
discretionary manager framework
cash can be viewed as a drag but it also
creates extraordinary optionality
because
uniquely among the assets that i hold it
gives me the ability to buy something
without having to sell something else
right optionality you get optionality
when you move to a passive strategy that
holds no cash
you lose that optionality right and so
that's a big chunk of what you're
actually giving up you effectively are
turning cash
into a toxic asset and if we saw this in
the oil market for example
just this year where if you have a toxic
asset
you eventually may be forced to pay
people to get
to take it from you right oil prices
went negative because
nobody could find storage to store this
toxic
product cash is functionally the same
to a passive investor
um so walk us through
why so i'm gonna give a good friend of
mine jim bianco i'm not sure if you know
jim but a good friend of mine jim bianco
um
gave me a few statistics this was in
january i was actually out in your neck
of the woods i was i
i was in california at the time at a
double line
event and when we were there he said and
i checked with them this morning the us
has
more than 12 000 investment advisory
firms
they employ more than 400 000 people
offering investment advisory services
more than 35 million investors use
investment advisors whose assets
recently topped 70 trillion
88 percent of investment advisors
currently use or recommend
etfs for their clients no other
investment vehicle has a higher usage
not even cash yeah
so that's if if i've understood
some of your prior comments that is not
necessarily there's probably overlap but
that is not necessarily one in the same
that 70 trillion dollar pile with
401k investing not at all
and so the the the vast majority of
401ks are actually
managed now within corporations using
out
you know outsourced service providers uh
you know examples would be like voyo
financial or others right they will
offer a limited menu of investment
vehicles
you can choose in many situations to opt
out and self-do what's called
self-direct your 401k
that requires many additional steps in
order to go through that process and so
it's one that very few people take
advantage of
but that tends to be an asset pool that
is separate and distinct from what
you're referring to when you talk about
registered investment advisors
registered investment advisor space has
been another area of growth and part of
the reason
why that growth has occurred is the
general pressure on fees in this
industry and that
in part can be thought of as a byproduct
of the just the disappearance of high
interest rates right so
you can afford to pay somebody one
percent of your assets or two percent of
your assets
when your cash is earning six percent
right when that hurdle rate is
effectively there when your cash is
earning zero
those costs become very
adverse to your portfolio and so there's
just been tremendous pressure on fees
in the industry both at the portfolio
manager level and the portfolio
management company level
and also at the registered investment
advisor level and so there's been
an extraordinary adoption of etfs
and index funds that can be offered by
registered investment advisors at
effectively no
fees while they themselves are then able
to charge
you know typically a one percent type
fee on their clients assets
and so their clients are getting a
quote-unquote reasonably priced dynamic
but the other thing that you're hitting
on this is that this is actually a big
industry it has a lot of people that
work in it those people
are often lambasted for working against
their client interests i'll be honest
with you that's the exception in my
experience rather than the rule the vast
majority of people really do want the
best for their clients
but we've been somewhat hamstrung by the
idea that the industry can't add
value right that effectively like
why would you do anything other than buy
the s p 500
or you know buy the nasdaq right
and part of that i would actually argue
is it is an unfortunate byproduct of
money flowing into those strategies
right so if a market is not frictionless
and money is flowing into a strategy
it's going to raise the price
of the securities that are in that
strategy that increase in price is what
we call a return
right that's a capital gain and so we
actually see out performance
that is being created by these very
dynamics
the problem of course is what happens
when people try to
exit the system and what are the false
signals that are received on an economic
basis
from prices that are increasingly
detached from fundamentals
um so have there been
any moments in the past few years that
you've seen
stress in the passive space
stress it was maybe quashed but are
there have there been times that you've
kind of seen cracks start to
erupt in the system yes very clearly i
mean so the
the two most obvious ones three most
obvious ones that i would point to and
they tend to be a byproduct
of the same thing that that you hear me
referring to which is effectively
crowded strategies right so
when a strategy becomes crowded it works
great
until people try to get out or an exit
needs to be obtained right and then you
suddenly discover and warn
buffet lexicon you know who's swimming
naked right right
um the the the events that i would point
to
um you know we had actually there's
there's a couple of them but
uh we had the february 2018 event that's
referred to as valmageddon
which was the collapse of the xiv and
related
vixx etf strategies that was one
where the size of the short volt trade
associated with the
inverse of the vix the xiv and related
product svxy there were a couple of them
actually
had become so large that it was
completely dominating
the market for what are referred to as
vic's futures or ux
futures and when an event occurred that
required
that to be exited on any normal day
those products were taking up 70
of the liquidity when you had a
significant
event that caused a general de-risking
and caused people to try to unwind those
trades
suddenly the requirement for liquidity
jumped to somewhere in the neighborhood
of 400
to a thousand percent of what was
actually available in the market
and exactly as we saw in 1987
transactions just stopped
the market makers stepped away they had
no contractual obligation to do so
and the product was able to fall in an
unconstrained fashion
that then turned around and bled into
the s p itself because people had to
hedge out their exposure to volatility
in one form or another
but that was a very clear example we had
a similar event in the fourth quarter of
where um a variety of products
also in the short volatility space what
was referred to as an iron condor type
strategy that was a
less risky version of some of the short
vol that had been in place
those began to unwind in significant
size at the same time
that we began to see the first impacts
in terms of flow
of baby boomer retirements right so when
a
when you hit 70.5 these rules have
changed slightly so it's important to
understand that
but when you hit 70.5 you have to start
taking distributions from your 401ks and
iras
2018 was kind of the first time we
really saw that happen in size and so it
you know a market event was created
around these dynamics
right go ahead and i mean i think it's
just important to
to contextualize what you're what you're
describing right because
uh february the 5th 2018 was jay pal's
first day in office and
the dow jones fell over a thousand
points and he was
he was much more of the paul volcker
philosophical
backstopping markets type not you know
not on my watch and
a few days later he gave his first
congressional testimony and said it's
not the fed's job to backstop markets at
which point armageddon went poof
and at the same time you know as what
you're talking about demographics
finally starting to play out
you'll remember uh you'll remember
because we're coming right up to the two
year anniversary of general electric's
debt being downgraded on halloween
2018 of that year and within 14 days
you know there was no there was no
issuance for 41 days
the jungle market froze so
that was a separate illiquidity event
that
it was exacerbated by what you're
describing going on in the background
and of course
led up to christmas eve yeah and so
you know if you if you remember um and
one of my friends
uh a gentleman by the name of vincent
gillard
at fcx stone has just written an
interesting piece that highlights
you know the dates and the dynamics of
when the markets have bottomed on these
last several
events right so february the february
5th event
um you know had a recovery off of it and
and you know you actually um before we
move off of that i actually would
highlight
i would actually say that the fed had a
bigger role
in those events than people are aware of
there was a change to what's called the
c car provisions right the capital
adequacy provisions
that occurred on february 2nd where they
changed a loophole
that it existed for shortfall positions
so the
risk capital that needed to be held
against an equity loan
was set so that um the risk
off event for an equity loan was a
instantaneous 30 percent decline in the
s p 500
right a repeat of the 1987 style events
the equivalent risk in terms of capital
required to hold a short volatility
position
in the vix products was a 10 point
increase in the vix
right now that's those are nowhere near
the same
right that's the equivalent of saying
there is no risk in short vole there's
extraordinary risk in owning equities
guess what happened prior to february
2nd 2018
large short vol positions built up
relative to long equity positions
which of course led people to look at
equity positions say oh it's not
extended there's no real risk here etc
but all the risk was actually in the
short vol products
that blew up when those c car provisions
were changed and suddenly the street had
to go out and seek
significant hedging against the
outstanding vol positions
so you know that's the sort of thing
where i would actually say it was much
less passive it was a function of
crowding and a fed
being unaware of what that change that
somewhat obscure change in c-car
provisions might set off
well the the the 59 trading days where
the vix
closed in 2017 south of 10.
it might have been a little bit of a
flag for uh for for the feds and
for regulators in general but that
that's wha i i was on the inside and
right after the crisis when they were
starting to you know
put extra provisions on banks at the
same time that liquidity was coming down
in the bond market
and i'm like you can't combine those two
that's like that ghostbusters scene
you're gonna cross the streams don't do
it and then
poof the bond market inventory blip
anyways um
no it won't be the last time that
regulators don't quite
understand the plumbing
and you've done a better job i think of
anyone else of highlighting that
you know i've gone on record as saying
for the most part i think the people at
the federal reserve are very well
intentioned
but there's a huge disconnect between
the academic literature and the
practitioner literature right and
i wouldn't even say literature
practitioner dynamics and
we know you can't step into a market
with billions of dollars and not
influence that market but that's the
explicit
assumption that underlines most of the
models right they tend to treat these
things
i mean as you know not having a phd in
economics i don't either
we're basically taught that markets are
occupied by people who make constant
mistakes against an expected value type
model right a very simplistic model
and so if you're trained to assume that
fluctuations in financial markets
are a byproduct of people constantly
making mistakes
it doesn't become particularly hard
philosophically to say oh
i'm going to step in and fix people's
mistakes because this is a mistake
right i'm going to correct them in a you
know very professorial or
stentonian centaurian tone right um
if that's your viewpoint if you think
that fluctuations are caused by mistakes
as compared to simply people with
different objective functions
different ages different utility
functions if i want to buy a house today
my need to sell is much greater than
somebody who might need to buy a house
10 years from now right and
not taking into account those disparate
motivations
as being quite distinct i think sets you
up to interfere in a market
in a potentially unproductive way on a
long term basis
feels good as you do it right everyone
seems at least somewhat happy
well and i think uh you know
i'm obviously not on the inside anymore
but
the the the shock of the coronavirus and
it was a black swan event it was a
shock but at the height of the great
financial crisis uh
corporate debt non-financial debt to gdp
was 74
we entered 2020 with 78 percent
so we entered with corporate america's
balance sheet more levered up than it
had ever been
coming out of this not qe era because
the fed absolutely
had to get reserves into the system
there was something very wrong with the
plumbing
in september of 2019 and people who were
in the trenches knew it
knew it um but there was there was
something
that felt very orchestrated about
march 23rd you know it i
you know and again i was not on the
inside but the coordination
and the the detailed
aspects of what the fed did tell me
that at least somebody at the new york
markets desk
came up with the game plan after you
know kind of the christmas eve bloodbath
that prompted
the powell pivot where he apologized on
january the 4th
2019 forever making these comments about
qe when he was a rookie in 2012 but
something tells me that the fed
knew the dangers and had started
studying it
when janet yellen made comments in front
of congress that she had some concerns
about
the collateral backing exchange traded
high-yield funds
and it's a whole different whole
different dynamic
if you wouldn't mind getting into
kind of crossing that other rubicon
it's not just the s p 500 now we've
delved into
exchange traded funds that are backed by
investment grade bonds high yield bonds
leverage loans for heaven's sake
so i this again is one of the things and
and i want to be clear when i say this
that i don't think that everything sits
you know passive isn't behind everything
but it is a huge
huge player in this and so particularly
when you talk about fixed income markets
i would actually suggest
that we are seeing tremendous growth by
you know in the the share gain for
passive bond indices is actually even
more rapid than the share gain that
occurred for equities and part of that
is a function of the market position and
distribution channels
of players like blackrock and vanguard
who are able to negotiate preferential
access
to any number of savings programs etc
and if you're a registered investment
advisor
you know vanguard and blackrock can
afford to take you out golfing while the
vast majority of people no longer really
can
right and so there's again not just cast
aspersions on the raas because that's
not what they're actually doing they
believe the research that says these are
the best products
but part of the challenge that is
created when you have these passive
vehicles that have this really simple
algorithm says if you give me cash then
buy and the construction of the indices
particularly within the fixed income
space is such that they are market value
weighted
which means that a company gets greater
representation or a debt security gets
greater representation
in the index the larger the issue is so
the more debt that is outstanding
and the second is the higher the price
is right and so perversely we all know
that fixed income
instruments will only return a fixed
amount over their lives
but paradoxically the construction of
these fixed income indices are such that
if a bond is trading at 150
it is 50 more attractive than a bond
that's trading at par
right 100. now that's insane we know
that's insane but that's how these
indices are constructed right and it
also
drives an underlying dynamic where if
you are
a issuer if you're a corporation that's
issuing debt
all you care about is that you get
vanguard or blackrock or one of the
index providers to buy your debt because
they're not going to do any analysis
on the covenants they're not going to do
any
analysis on your ability to repay etc
they're going to assume
everybody else has done that work
and as a result if the wall of money is
going into people who assume that
everyone else has done the work
you end up with debts that are priced as
if
they're flawless right and they're
distinctly flawed many of these
securities that occupy these indices
no longer have the covenants associated
with them they're what referred to as
cub light or no
covenant in many situations those aren't
debt securities
right debt securities actually give you
a preferential right to direct
management once the asset value has
fallen below a certain level if you have
no covenants to enforce that
you've just bought really terrible
equity but that's how these
these funds and these indices are
constructed
yeah if um i i actually just did a deep
dive
into recovery rates and because we've
got
quietly in the background we have
bankruptcies running at the highest
since 2009.
uh and recovery is running well below
them
right i mean that's recoveries were 79
cents on the dollar
uh and that was as bad as they got on
leveraged loans right now they're 47
cents
and and high yield bond recoveries are
15 cents
on the dollar i mean the lowest we got
last time i think was 22 cents under all
i mean these are i
i can't even wrap my head around this
stuff stop and think about this we
literally just had
saber energy which was a high yield
issuer in the energy space
their bonds went no recovery goldman
sachs had to take the bonds because
there was no bid for the assets
yes right i mean i i i don't think i've
ever seen that happen for a publicly
traded security before but that's
exactly what you would expect to happen
when the only buyer is an index provider
that assumes that whatever price it was
able to come out at is the right price
which
sets up an incentive structure for me as
a participant in the underwriting
to say okay well i can dump it off to
vanguard as long as i know that it's
going to go into this index
the corporation gains extraordinary
leverage the management team gains
extraordinary leverage because they're
able to construct this with no covenants
etc
right and as a result we're getting
exactly what you would expect
an incredible mispricing of the worst
quality debt we've ever seen
i mean when we came into when we came
into 2020
morgan stanley did just the back of the
envelope that said
42 of the investment grade universe on
planet earth
should have been rated junk and was not
and that's why i say that it feels like
there was such a script behind
what the fed was doing because they
backstopped grandfathered in and
backstopped anything
that was downgraded as a fallen angel
from investment grade to high yield
after march the 22nd and now he's had
record fallen angels
and we just i feel like we are still in
the process
of whistling past the graveyard and
i mean my final question to you which
i'm not going to get to yet
is has has to do with what can break
this dynamic
but first i want to ask you a little bit
more of a philosophical
question uh because there has been
something of an
outgrowth of a combination of
indexing and don't fight the fed and
you know not to be there's no hyperbole
here but but have we returned to a sort
of
robber uh robber baron era in the united
states where in
the way markets are structured feeds
into
the growth of some of the largest
companies
along with this idea of don't fight the
fed you just need to be long
well so i i um
yes i think that we are in a new robber
baron era and i do
think that the structure of the markets
particularly the dynamics of passive
investing
facilitates the accumulation of capital
at the highest levels
right and so just very quickly i
referred to the financial to the fixed
income bond
uh index construction where market value
determines how much money goes into a
into an issue or into a company we have
the same thing as it relates to
equities right so they are float
weighted or market cap weighted
in terms of their construction that
means that if they go up in price
the next dollar that comes in puts more
money in on a relative basis right and
so it creates momentum
and that's exactly what we've seen has
been the dominance of momentum
strategies
over value strategies which would
require
people to make a discretionary choice of
is this a good value
or is it a bad value right and so what
we've done is we've taken money away
from those making those discretionary
choices given it to those
who only make momentum choices and we've
created a continued
inflow of capital because of the
dominance of passive vehicles and things
like
401ks so while we talk about passive
share being somewhere in the
neighborhood of 50
of managed assets about 40 percent of us
equity assets overall about 25 of us
fixed income assets
that's a very poor characterization of
the actual structure of the market
because the younger generations those
who are actively saving as compared to
those who are withdrawing their capital
they're over 90 passive all right so all
the money that's coming in
more than 100 of the flows into the
market
is coming into passive vehicles that
have these momentum weights
and what of course that means is is that
each incremental dollar more
of it goes to an apple or to a google or
to a microsoft
than it does to other securities and
in our analysis at least that creates a
disparate impact that
that creates a reinforcing loop on that
type of momentum behavior
and the only way that ends is when money
starts to come
out of those types of strategies
um well we'll again
hold that thought for just another uh
but is there a difference between
kind of blindly having
most of your of your proceeds most of
what you're saving
on your behalf flowing into a 401k and
actively building a diversified
portfolio of etfs so you've got each i
mean
you've got etfs everywhere i think
they're more etfs now than there are
mutual funds
uh but but are
are there certain venues are there
certain uh portfolios where
you can build out kind of a traditional
think about the efficient frontier
a traditional well-diversified portfolio
of etfs
um so one of the interesting things is
while there's been a massive
proliferation of etfs
um there's i personally track somewhere
in the neighborhood of 1500 etfs right
so
i know there's more than that but that's
the cutoff basically
of that 1500 which are the largest etfs
in the us markets only 50 are gaining
assets
right so the etf space in aggregate
is really dominated by a few small
players like
voo the vanguard etf vbr
which is a another you know vanguard
type products blackrock type products
state steep street type products some
invesco products
just completely dominate the growth
that's occurring in the industry
those account for more than 100 of the
flows that are going into the etf space
and so the kind of
you know interesting thematic sort of
thing like you know
a robot etf or a green energy etf those
will occasionally capture people's
attention
but they don't really fit into the very
simple asset allocation models that many
registered investment advisors and
financial advisors are choosing for
their clients
they kind of treat it as like well
that's play money right you can put a
little bit into those but at your core
should be
the vanguard total market index a
vanguard bond index
you know a uh vanguard international
exposure and a vanguard
maybe a small cap or a vanguard uh
you know uh tax advantaged uh
bond type fund right whether that's tips
or anything else right
super simple portfolios that's what
everybody is looking for
they want simplicity and the etfs play
into that but only in a very narrow
space
so um how how does the fed and qe play
into how and i'm speaking
i'm speaking more about the actual level
of
purchases made on a on a monthly basis
all of that money
pouring into the financial system how
does that make its way through
to bolstering liquidity
helping put a floor underneath markets
well i think that's one of the things
that's so fascinating is is this idea of
a fed put or this idea that the fed will
step in to
bail out investors and and is there to
protect investors
that's really only a narrative that
occurs amongst discretionary managers
right i mean no one who is 25 years old
who's
participation in their the stock market
is tied to their 401k at work where
their employer has a three percent match
and you know they're automatically
routed into let's say they're 25 years
old so they'll turn
65 you know sometime in 2070 give or
uh yeah 20 20 75
they're gonna be in a target date fund
that is tied to
that maturity right that end of their
working
you know life nowhere in that strategy
does it say hey do you think the fed is
going to increase interest rates or
lower interest rates
uh at the next meeting right that
participation isn't involved in any way
shape or form nor is it incorporated
into the behavior of these target date
funds that now represent the vast
majority of the money that is going into
these types of products
where the discretion occurs is on the
part of the active manager
who says i think the fed is going to
step in therefore there's very little
risk therefore i don't need to hold cash
or i might even lever my portfolio to
gain
increased exposure to try to keep up
with the benchmarks right
that that i think is where that dialogue
of don't fight the fed etcetera exists
and we see this and the risk on risk-off
behavior
which is often a function of the active
discretionary managers
changing their direction or their
loadings and so that's what we really
saw
in the spring of 2020 there was no
change until the layoffs began
in march there was no change to
contributions in 401ks there was
nothing nothing changed right
and yet suddenly the active managers got
cold feet and they said oh my gosh this
is really really terrible we need to
sell
and so they tried to raise cash and
discovered that
their lowering prices in order to
facilitate that
didn't attract additional buyers right
that same
25 year old doesn't get an alert from
their 401k that says hey prices are down
5 versus yesterday
would you like to buy more right it just
doesn't happen
and as a result when they went to try to
sell
on that risk-off event there were no
more buyers prices collapsed
now in terms of the fed behavior and
kind of this 23rd date
i think there's a couple of different
components that go into that
one is absolutely the fed stepped in
with some very targeted actions for
example supporting bond funds through
blackrock
right hiring blackrock to allocate
capital
is kind of the ultimate example to me of
you know giving the fox control of
feeding the hens
right the second thing though that
happened and this is one of those
weird market structure things that
people tend not to be aware of and again
i mentioned
the work of my friend vincent the 23rd
is roughly the date
at which a target date fund would have
to look at their portfolio and say okay
we are supposed to have a balance
between equities and bonds
the bonds have risen the equities have
fallen
so much so what am i going to do i'm
going to
sell bonds and i'm going to buy equities
right that's what they have to do
contractually in their
in their target date fund structure
well there's a ready buyer for bonds
because the fed just announced that
they're going to increase the quantity
of bonds that they're going to buy
right so selling those bonds is easy
and going out and buying the equities
starts to drive the price of the
equities higher and immediately everyone
says
oh guess what it was because of fed qe
that stock prices went up that's
i think there's some truth to that but i
actually think that it has much more to
do with the systematic dynamics and
those dynamics have governed the last
four events march 23rd 2018 which was
the bottom associated with vol again
december 24th on 2018 it would have been
the 23rd
if that hadn't been a sunday so the 24th
is is the next day that's available to
you
then again we had it occur in september
23rd of 2000
uh it was 2019
that it was september 23rd and then we
had march 23rd again in 2020 these are
after option experience these are at the
point that the target date funds have to
start the rebalancing
is the fed aware of this i mean i've had
conversations with them i think they're
starting to be aware of it and so they
may there may be some coordination of
okay now would be a really good time
because it allows us to pretend that
we're actually doing this
but i'm a little skeptical that the fed
is actually fully aware of this
so what what is the magnitude of
versus let's say the 70 trillion that i
brought up before with rias that are
88 flowing into these etfs what is the
magnitude of target date funds kind of
just a broad versus this 70 trillion
dollar
kind of monster out there well so
it's quite small relative to that 70
trillion monster but remember that that
70 trillion monster incorporates all
global assets
right so when you talk about the size of
these products
particularly for younger generations in
equities they become pretty meaningful
so
total market cap in the united states is
around three trillion
on any given day you're going to see
kind of
you know tens to hundreds of billions of
dollars worth trade
but remember that the difference on that
is quite small
right so if apple trades two billion
dollars worth of shares in a day but the
price only moves by a penny
that tells you that you had a pretty
tight balance between the buyers and the
sellers
if the price goes up a dollar or down a
dollar right
then that actually is telling you that
there was an imbalance in one direction
or another
right and so when the the target date
funds are stepping in as they did on
march 23rd
of 2020 and buying because of an
underweight of like 10
you're potentially talking somewhere in
the neighborhood of 100 to 200 billion
dollars worth of equity buying that has
to occur
that's giant yeah on any on any
given trading day absolutely yes so you
know it was interesting that right
before
his death that vogel said that passive
had become too big and
he was starting to make some rumblings
almost as if he'd been
talking on the phone with you uh about
passing this 50 line in the sand
uh and what the implications would be
if passive was really no longer passive
anymore because it was so
big yeah so i i think bogel had a
different
had a difficult place in history because
unquestionably his products
are adopted and used by millions of
americans and have
created a tremendous amount of wealth
but his relationship with his the firm
he founded vanguard actually became
quite strained
in the late 1990s as vanguard began to
capitalize
on its market position and introduce
products
that made him nervous right so things
like etfs things like
active rebalancing he was generally
opposed to that and as you mentioned
as of kind of may 2017 he gave a speech
in which he said
you know if everyone were to go passive
it would be complete disaster markets
would fail
right most people tend to think that's
way off into the future
and the reason that they think that is
because they assume that markets are
truly liquid transparent relatively
frictionless etc
the data increasingly just doesn't
support that right the the the
participation in
in a strategy can very rapidly crowd a
market
even one as large as the s p 500 or the
u.s equity markets
so uh you're you're ending this
perfectly
and uh demographically
is one aspect fundamentally is
another i mean from my perch following
the macroeconomy we're seeing permanent
joblessness rise
we're seeing joblessness climb up the
income ladder into white collar
uh we're also seeing what looks to be uh
not necessarily a second wave of the
virus but a
full-blown second wave of layoffs and
bankruptcies which had tamp down in
august and september look to be picking
back up
in october and i think if a lot of
companies feel that
the last few months of 2020 aren't going
to be this massive rebound that had been
factored in and priced in so
where do demographics play into passive
investing
and do will fundamentals ever matter
because again what you're describing and
listening to
i don't listen to it i keep it on mute
but when when
bloomberg's on in the background there
is a lot of talk about
the idea of qe infinity in fact fed
policymakers are saying that qe is going
to be a permanent fixture
going forward and i think that that has
the potential to provide reassurance to
people
that status quo as it is today with
markets just
generally speaking having hiccups along
the way but but
rising steadily is what what could upset
that dynamic
well i mean there's a variety of things
that can upset the dynamic demographics
of course is one of them because we have
a large accumulated stockpile of assets
associated with the boomers and those
older than the boomers that
need to be liquidated right so when we
talk about iras or 401ks combined
they're about 17 and a half trillion
dollars in assets
as they are increasingly managed by
things like target date funds or
robo advisor type frameworks it says you
should have x amount
in the s p 500 x amount in small cap x
amount
in international stocks et cetera as
that becomes more and more a function
of pre-programmed ages right and people
are looking for these very simplistic
rather than idiosyncratically composed
portfolios for all their flaws
at least people were doing somewhat
different things right
but when you have this sort of
demographic dynamic associated with the
baby boomers that ultimately need to
sell those assets
in order to fund their retirements to
fund their consumption
the real risk that you have is the
increase in fragility that's created
by these super simplistic algorithms
that simply say
if you give me cash then buy and
likewise if you ask for cash then sell
well what price should i sell whatever
price i can get
right and that suggests to me that what
we're likely to see
is this type of behavior where equities
continue to become
more volatile fixed income continues to
become more volatile
as the process of price discovery is
increasingly impaired by these actors
because you're you're saying sell at
whatever price there is out there so put
in a market sell
well and and the perverse dynamic is so
the boston fed a
friend of mine at the boston fed um an
individual i respect a lot put out a
piece recently talking about passive
investing and does it represent
systematic risk right and
one of the things that they highlight
about things like etfs is that
potentially they reduce liquidity
demands because instead of being sold
for cash
they could theoretically be returned in
kind right so instead of you
having to sell your hyg and receiving
cash for it at a distressed price
well they could just give you the
underlying bonds right and i look at
that and i go that's
the most insane thing i've ever heard
right like what is the average american
going to do with a low-grade bond that
was suddenly deposited into their
account
when they asked for cash they're going
to sell it without any form of
professional trader
who's trying to find the best execution
price they're just going to dump it into
the market this is
this is a complete disaster if that's
what you think is providing liquidity
and they have to like they know this
they have to know that's the case
but there's an extraordinary amount of
effort that is being put out
by organizations that people think
are working in their interest right
vanguard has a great story
about how they're out there for the
small investor etc and the
crazy part is i think they actually
believe it it's very cult-like behavior
there
but at the end of the day that's not a
solution and we saw this
you know many vanguard bond etf products
i would highlight something like bnd
for example that went to a that went to
a
seven percent discount to its nav in the
events of march 2020.
right now that's 70 treasuries so what
that's telling you is is that the
corporate bond component of it which is
all investment grade
had to be trading at a 21 discount
like that's not a liquid product under
those conditions and that's why i would
argue that the fed stepped in
so aggressively to try to mitigate those
risks on a short-term basis
but exactly as you said they separated
us from the fundamentals which continue
to deteriorate many of those situations
well
there was a time in the days that
preceded that the long bond itself was
not trading in asian and
trading in the middle of the night so i
mean
yeah there are lots of challenges
associated with that it was just
not what it used to be no it is
definitely and i think it's important
for people to remember
that liquidity doesn't always mean what
we think it means so when the fed
adds liquidity it doesn't mean that
they're actually out there facilitating
the transaction of the securities that
you happen to own
what they're actually saying when they
provide liquidity is is that they are
allowing people who
want to trade to borrow and post
collateral so that they can execute
right and by the same token we're not
seeing commercial and industrial loans
go up you know the revolvers were
initially drawn down
and now the reserves are just banks are
piling into more and more and more
treasuries every day they're not they're
not making new loans
well and and we see not just that we
also see you know that tends to come
through as various forms of
misinformation right so
when a cni uh loan is taken down or when
a more importantly a line of credit
right a revolver is taken down that
money flows into a money market mutual
fund
and that then gets reported to the
public as oh look cash balances have
exploded
right and there's tons of tons of cash
on the sidelines
well there's a huge difference between
cash that was raised by
individuals in their brokerage accounts
and
cash that was created because lines of
credit or
revolvers have been drawn down in
advance of the event those can't be used
to buy stocks
right and those ultimately have to be
repaid there's a subsequent withdrawal
of that liquidity
that is approaching and when that occurs
i would expect to see further stress in
the credit markets
yeah and you've already heard banks say
that they're they're already taking
losses on some of the retailers who
drew down those lines and are no longer
with us absolutely
um any last words on on fundamentals i i
know that's not kind of your
your specialty if you will but but i'd
be curious to hear
what your views are given this
extraordinary macroeconomic backdrop not
just here in the united states but heck
globally
well so i would actually highlight that
the united states tends to be our focus
for the very simple reason that it's the
largest most liquid market
and people tend to focus on the fact
that the united states is disadvantaged
because we have to go to the rest of the
world to satisfy
many of our consumption needs right so
we run large trade deficits for example
right
well part of the problem with that is
what you're actually saying with the
trade deficit is is that we're
interested in consuming
things like you know trinkets from china
or
semiconductors or iphones or various
other things
but we're actually providing the
aggregate demand to the rest of those
countries around the world
right so if we step away you know i have
this conversation with people regularly
if we step away
where does china turn to meet its
consumption needs
it's certainly not china because china
has a shrinking population and labor
force at this point
right europe is the exact same japan is
the exact same
the only place around the world that has
a growing market for consumption goods
is the united states
and if we can't afford to do that
because of adverse outcomes here
then the rest of the world takes it much
worse in my analysis
and so as bad as things are here
i think we sometimes do ourselves a
disservice by not paying attention to
what's happening to the rest of the
world
the other thing that that you're
highlighting is that
the cares act and the paycheck
protection program
effectively bought us time and turned
many forms of labor
into a cost plus exercise right so we
will lend you
money that we expect to forgive that
allows you to pay your employees
and you can keep 40 of it to cover other
costs like the rent of
your unit right in many situations
small business people took advantage of
both
didn't pay the rent didn't hold reserves
to ultimately
repay the loans that they've taken out
with the expectations they're going to
be forgiven
effectively kept their employees on but
allowed the real options to expire and i
would suggest that we've seen a lot of
this we've seen people that have delayed
paying their rents that have now
accumulated rents there's no prospect of
getting current on
people who have delayed paying their
mortgage there's no prospect of getting
current on those mortgages
right people have delayed it on
commercial properties
as a result you're going to see a large
number of businesses that have cleared
out their inventory and sold
it off just go away right and
all of those things are in process right
now to me
it's actually quite distressing to watch
what's happening
because the last part is policy makers
tend to
look to the expectations channel going
back to that 1970s discussion
they tend to look to the expectations
channel to tell them how urgent it is
that they do something
and so when equity markets and bond
markets are trading at all-time highs
they look at it and say well it's not
that urgent whereas in march with
markets down dramatically oh my gosh
it's the second great depression
we have to move very very quickly we
have to have giant amount of stimulus
etc
now you're seeing everyone basically
saying yeah not that urgent
right exactly the opposite it's i would
argue it's the exact opposite i think it
was incredibly urgent in march
um what i've highlighted for people is
that i think we've made almost every
possible mistake we could in the interim
period and instead of
getting our economy back to work we
chose that to use that largess to shut
it down
and you know further cement kind of the
permanent damage that
that you're highlighting so effectively
well i hope that we can come together uh
in
you know in another six months or so and
look back on 2020
and uh and and not have other
other things that end with aged to talk
about
i'm not sure how this is going to go but
uh but i do appreciate all of your time
you do a great
service explaining something that for
most people
is a passive thought so uh whereas they
they need to be much more
active in fact the first thing i'm going
to do is is tell my friends with big
401ks that if they jump through a bunch
of hoops that they can self-direct them
so that's what i think that's important
and i think one of
the real challenges unfortunately is
that your audience and my audience
people that pay attention to this sort
of stuff
are actually naturally prone to being
thoughtful about it
right it's the people that aren't
listening that
tend to be you know for many of the
people that are in our audience there's
frustration because it's not clear what
you should do but there's an awareness
that something needs to be done at least
that's
the first part of the battle vast
majority of people they just aren't
thinking about this
well i hope we've changed that to some
degree today
hope so i hope so this will be a broader
audience than what you're used to
excellent well thank you very much
danielle
thank you take good care uh enjoy living
out there in that perfect weather while
the rest of us descend into winter and
for valuetainment this is danielle
dimartino booth and thank you so much
for joining today
well that might have been more than most
people can wrap their heads around
in an hour and a half but i learned a
lot i hope that you learned a lot
listening to mike green
uh this is danielle dimartino booth with
down the middle
with dimartino booth and i hope you join
me next time and if you happen to have
missed my discussion
with brigadier general robert spalding
you can catch that right here
i look forward to your comments thank
[Music]
you